(soft electronic music)
- I think we can all agree
that it is very difficult
to understand the brain.
Part of the reason is
because the sheer number
of neurons we have to study.
There's about 100 billion
stars in our galaxy,
but if you look at the human brain,
there's about the same number of neurons.
It's also about 100 billion.
But what make it even more difficult
is that on average,
each neuron is connected
with about 10,000 other neurons.
Even when you look at
a much smaller brain,
for example that of a mouse,
there's still about 100
millions of neurons,
with that forming about
100 billion connections.
What make it difficult to understand
is not just the sheer amount of numbers.
The thing is there's also mental activity
that we really want to
be able to understand.
For example, perception,
attention, or consciousness
is really an emergent property
of not just a few neurons,
but instead those millions
up to billions of neurons
that form a neural
network or neural circuit
by forming a connection with each other,
which we call synapses.
So, it's not enough to
only try to understand
the, you know, 100 neurons,
even though you can already
know a lot about the universe
by looking at the 100 stars
that are formed at different stage.
So, condense all this
into a scientific
question that we can ask,
the first set of questions
we want to understand
is how a single neuron operates.
For example, a single neuron
in the cortex may receive 10,000 inputs.
We want to know what are those inputs,
and we also want to know
how this individual neuron
integrated all the inputs it received
to generate an output signal.
So another way to answer the question is,
what is input-output relationship
for the individual neuron in the brain.
After we understand that,
we can then look at how multiple neurons,
actually tens of thousands of neurons
that are working together
by forming a circuit,
and what are the inputs
those circuit receive,
and how individual
neurons within a circuit
encode the sensory stimuli,
or actually to execute a neural
command, a motor command.
So, in order to do that,
we really need to spend
a very large scale, both
in space and in time
as Mark mentioned previously.
So for imaging method,
what we would like to have
is that we'd like to have
sub-micron spatial resolution
because that is the size
of individual synapses.
Those are the size of the
connections between neurons.
But we also want to be able to have
millisecond-scale time
resolution because of how quickly
the neuro signaling happen in the brain.
We want to be able to
image all those processes
at depths because brain's
this three-dimensional,
rather thick structure, which
in all the adult brains,
they are also scattering.
So one of the technique that
has been around for many years,
which is very powerful in this aspect,
are the so called two-photon
fluorescence microscopy.
So this microscopy rely on the excitation
of a fluorescent molecule
by the absorption
of two photons at the same time.
And then when the molecule
come back to the ground state,
it will release its energy
in the form of a fluorescent photon.
The nice thing about this technique
is that the fluorescent
signal is only generated
at the focus of your excitation laser.
So in order to form an image of the brain,
what you only need to do
is just to scan this focus
around inside the brain and connect
to the fluorescent
signal at each position.
And then when you plot out this
two-dimensional Raster Plot,
that basically gonna give you a micrograph
of the fluorescent molecule distribution.
As this example show, you can see
that there's a special resolution
of this technique is clearly sufficient,
since you are able to see individual
dendritic spines in vivo.
But there's a problem
when you try to image,
going beyond the two-dimensional image.
And this is important because
from a single neuron to a neural circuit,
this is really a
three-dimensional structure.
If you only scan in a 2D plane,
you will only be able to have
a cross sectional view of the sample.
So, in order to get the
volumetric imaging of the neuron,
you basically need to scan.
You basically need to scan
this focus in three-dimension.
So you can see that it takes time.
And secondly, sometimes
your sample may be moving,
and then you will have this motion-induced
artifact in your image.
And finally, if you want to really have
high volumetric imaging speed,
the traditional approach
is basically trying to move
this laser focus very
rapidly in three-dimension.
So assume that you can do that,
what will then happen is that
now you will have a huge amount of data
'cause you go from a two-dimensional image
now to a three-dimensional image stack.
And because of this motion
problem that you want to correct,
now you need to do three-dimensional
motion registration,
which is very difficult to do
when you're dealing
with gigabytes of data.
And typically, traditional
neurobiology laboratory
are not really equipped either in terms
of computational hardware and expertise
to really handle this type of big data.
And finally, the actual
volume rate is still limited
by the brightness of the
fluorescent molecule.
Even if you can move the
laser focus very rapidly,
the focus is still required to stay
at each individual position
for an amount of enough time
for you to gather enough
photon to see the structure.
So when we was confronted
with this problem,
we asked ourselves this question,
is this traditional approach of scanning
this focus in 3D absolutely necessary?
And before I give you the answer,
I want to show you that
those are the neurons
in the brain, and you can
see individual circles.
Those are the cell body
of individual neurons.
And those are the dendritic
spines of a single neuron.
So there's lots of things happening.
You see flashes of
fluorescence intensity change,
which is basically telling you
that these neurons are becoming active.
But despite of all those activities,
you would probably also notice
is that nothing is changing.
I mean, sorry, the neurons
are not moving around.
Most of things are changing,
but the neurons stay put.
Maybe because of the actual
cell (mumbles) metrics
that are holding them in space.
But they are so stationary,
that they are even,
they even have constant position
on the label of a single synapse.
So this means now, we
actually have a choice,
which is specifically true
if you have a sparsely labeled sample.
You could do this conventional scan,
and then for a sparsely labeled sample,
you will spend lots of
time looking at nothing.
Or what you could do is to
stretch out your excitation focus
so that by scanning this
focus once in two-dimension,
you will have a projected
view of the same volume.
But the advantage here is
that the imaging frame rate,
in this particular case
is 30 frames per second,
now become your volume rate.
So here you are looking
at the volume of brain
inside the awake behaving mouse.
And you can see the neurons
become brighter and dimmer,
reflecting the activity
of this particular neuron.
So, this type of focus
where we stretch it in the axial direction
is called Bessel focus or Bessel beam.
And this conventional type of
focus where it's very small
is an axial direction
called Gaussian beam.
Now, Bessel beam is actually
not something very exotic.
Whenever you go to supermarket,
and you go to the checkout line,
they will have this red light
that is reading the bar code.
Those red lights are actually Bessel beam.
But when we use this for two-photon
fluorescence microscopy though,
we can't just use whatever is inside
our checkup line in our supermarket.
So what we did is that we
built a very simple module
that is located between
our excitation laser
and the two-photon microscope.
I'm not gonna go through the detail,
but we use this metal equipment
called the spatial light modulator,
which allow us to generate the Bessel beam
of different length as
well as the narrowness.
So here are just two examples.
On the right hand side is
what the excitation focus
actually looks like in
the axial direction.
I just want to point out that,
to the actual size, you have
to stretch this whole thing
by five times because it's
just too narrow to show it
if I show you with its real aspect ratio.
So you can see that when we
use a longer Bessel beam,
in this case about 60 micron
in the axial direction,
you can see more structures.
But one thing I want to point out is that
if you compare the image you get
with what you have gotten with
the conventional approach,
you can notice that we maintain
the ability to resolve
individual synapses.
For example, there's
about three axonal boutons
in this Gaussian image,
which is clearly detected
in the Bessel images as well.
So one big advantage of this approach
is that now the imaging become insensitive
to the axial motion.
So what do I mean by that?
So here are the image of a
stretch of dendrite in a mouse
taken with a Gaussian beam
as well as a Bessel beam.
So you can see there's
quite a bit of motion
because this animal is awake
and hasn't been fully
habituated to have fixation.
And we can easily register this image
in 2D just to correct the matter of shift.
And then, now you can
see it doesn't jitter
in the XY direction as much.
And if you now plot out
the fluorescence intensity
within this small stretch of dendrite,
you can see that in the Gaussian data
you see this up and down signal,
which actually looks very much
like the calcium activity
that you would expect
to see when the neuron become active.
However, when you look at the Bessel data,
you don't see such open,
those transient-like variations.
Now, we could also quantify
how much the brain is moving.
And when we do that, you actually realize
that all those transients we see here
are very strongly correlated
with the motion of the brain.
So then you can say, well,
how do you know this is not activity?
It could still be some kind
of motion-induced activity of the neuron.
But we know in this case
it cannot be activity
because we are not expressing
calcium indicator in the brains.
In this case, it's just very simple
yellow fluorescence protein.
So, by using a Bessel beam,
now we really don't need
to worry about whether the data you get
is contaminated by motion artifact or not.
So as I mentioned before,
we have synaptic activity,
and this really help us to do a subtype
of neurobiological experiment,
where we ask the question,
what are the synaptic input
a single neuron receive?
So here, you are looking
at a 3D imaging stack
of dendrites of a neuron.
You can see there are dendritic spines
distributed at different depth.
And the question here
we are asking is that
what are the orientations and activity
each synaptic, each dendritic spine's,
of the inputs each synaptic
spines are receiving?
Now if you want to
interrogate all the spines
within this volume using
the conventional approach,
the experiment is gonna
take about 10 hours.
But with Bessel beam, we
could probe the orientations
and activity of those synaptic inputs
in a single session, which
only will take 20 minutes.
So we have about 30 times
increase of the throughput.
And if you analyze this data,
you can then gather the tuning property
of all the dendritic spines in one row,
and in this particular case,
we observe some clustering
of inputs of similar type.
Now we are not limited to this
dendritic type of imaging.
Any kind of sparsely labeled sample
can be studied using this method.
So here we are looking at inhibitory
neuron population in the mouse brain.
And using the conventional
approach to probe
the first 400 micron
of inhibitory neurons,
we need to take at least 80 images.
But with Bessel approach,
we only need to take
four images, and by doing that,
in each imaging session,
we can get lots of neurons.
And by looking at this
data, we very easily realize
this triangle that is a subpopulation
of neurons have very highly
synchronized activity.
So if you are into interneurons,
then you will answer the question
that there are many
subtypes of interneurons.
We can label a particular
subtype called the VIP neuron,
and you can again see that
with a Bessel approach,
we can get all those VIP
neurons in one imaging session.
And when we look at their activity,
we actually found that those neurons
are highly synchronized.
And we further discovered
that the activities
very much correlated with the diameter
of the pupil of the mouse.
So now what does that mean?
It is known that if
your pupil are dilated,
that means you are paying attention.
So I hope all you guys' pupil
are dilated at this moment.
But what we basically
discovered is that VIP neuron
as a population has extremely
synchronized activity
reflecting the arousal level.
Now, if you are interneuron field,
the next cell type you
will want to look at
are the so-called somatostatin neuron.
The reason is because the current model,
most dominant model,
is that the VIP neuron
will inhibit somatostatin neuron.
If this model is correct,
then what you will expect
is the somatostatin neurons' activity
to be always anticorrelated
with the pupil.
But that's not what we see.
We do see anticorrelated population,
but we also see lots of population
that are also correlated.
So this means that this is really
a probably too simplistic picture,
and somatostatin neuron really
has heterogeneous activity
that wasn't appreciated before.
Now we actually didn't set
out to make this discovery,
but because we can image
at a high throughput,
this kind of conclusion just
naturally fall out of data
with a minimum amount of data analysis.
One thing I think will make
this technique very powerful
is that it is very easy
to add this capacity
to an existing microscope.
So my post-doc, Rongwen, flew down
to Max Planck Florida Institute,
and it took him only one day to install
a Bessel beam scanning module
on a commercial microscope
in the David Fitzpatrick lab.
And because biology are much harder,
they then spent a lot
longer trying to gather
this high super synaptic
imaging to work in ferrets.
So, since we published the result,
we've been helping multiple
labs to implement this method.
While we were doing that,
we realized there's two limitation
of the implementation that
we designed originally.
Number one is the limitation of money
because the spatial light modulator
is rather expensive equipment.
It's about $25,000.
Not every lab can easily come up
with the money to afford it.
Secondly is space.
Especially for labs that are
using commercial microscope,
oftentimes, it's a very compact design,
so it's difficult to fit in
an SLM-based module into those space.
So an alternative is to use the optics
that the checkout line also uses
called axicon to generate the Bessel beam.
It's much cheaper.
The whole module now is only about $5,000,
and it's very much more compact.
But the problem with axicon-based method
is that you cannot really tune
how long your Bessel beam will be.
But my post-doc Rongwen figured out
that you can simply translate
a lens inside the module,
and by doing that, we can
generate a Bessel beam
of different length very easily.
So again, here you need
to stretch out the focus
about 10 times to
appreciate the real length.
So because this system is so compact,
we can now easily implement
it on any kind of microscope.
One particular microscope
that is of interest here is a mesoscope
that was designed and built by the group
of Karel Svoboda at Janelia Farm.
So this microscope has
very large field of view.
It's about five millimeter,
which covers about 50% of
half hemisphere of cortex.
And I also want to mention
that there's this remote
focusing unit there,
which allows them to very rapidly move
the focus in a Z direction.
So we can combine the Bessel
module with the mesoscope.
This is how the whole module looks like
relative to the microscope.
And now we can probe a very large volume
of neurons at very high resolution.
For example, here we keep zooming in
into this very large field of view,
and you can still see we maintain
the resolution to see dendritic spines.
And just a few nice movies.
By combining this with functional imaging,
now we can do actual large volumetric
functional imaging at high speed.
So this a 300 Gaussian image
frame of a single neuron,
labeled in the mouse cortex.
And we can just translate
the Bessel beam six times.
We can cover the same volume,
and in this case, we can
now monitor the activity
while maintaining the ability
to see individual synapses.
And remember at the beginning of my talk,
I mentioned the goal
of being able to study
the input-output relationship
of a single neuron.
Now we really have the
technique to do that,
you know, awake behaving animal.
The very last example I wanna show
is when we look at not
just a single neurons,
but also on cell bodies in our circuit.
So here, we are looking
at an actual large volume.
Those are the inhibitory neurons
from the first 650 micron
thick in the mouse brain.
And we can image this whole volume,
1.3 millimeter by three
millimeter by 600 micron volume
of inhibitory neuron
activity at one hertz.
And we're still doing data analysis,
but just subset of data
give us about 1,700 neuron
of the activity information.
So I just wanna quickly summarize.
This work was made by the post-doc Rongwen
with help from many
biologists and collaborators,
both inside and outside Janelia.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
(soft electronic music)